[Music]
on March 3rd 1913 protesters parted for
the woman in white dressed in a flowing
cape and sitting astride a white horse
the activist Ynez milhollin was hard to
miss she was riding at the helm of the
women's suffrage parade the first mass
protest for a woman's right to vote on a
national scale
after months of strategic planning and
controversy thousands of women gathered
in Washington DC here they called for a
constitutional amendment granting them
the right to vote by 1913 women's rights
activists had been campaigning for
decades as a disenfranchised group women
had no voice in the laws that affected
their or anyone else's lives however
they were struggling to secure a broader
support for political equality they'd
achieved no major victories since 1896
when Utah and Idaho enfranchised women
that brought the total number of states
which recognized a woman's right to vote
- for a new media savvy spirit arrived
in the form of Alice Paul she was
inspired by the British suffragettes he
went on hunger strikes and endured
imprisonment in the early 1900's rather
than conduct costly campaigns on a
state-by-state basis Paul saw the
long-lasting impact of a constitutional
amendment which would protect women's
voting rights nationwide as a member of
the National American women's suffrage
association Paul proposed a massive
pageant to whip up support and
rejuvenate the movement Washington
authorities initially rejected her plan
and then tried to relegate the march to
side streets but Paul got those
decisions overturned and confirmed a
parade for the day before the
presidential inauguration of Woodrow
Wilson this would maximize media
coverage and grab the attention of the
crowds who would be in town
however in planning the parade Paul
mainly focused on appealing to white
women from all backgrounds including
those who were racist she actively
discouraged African American activists
and organizations from participating and
stated that those who did so should
march in the back but black women did
not be made invisible in a national
movement they helped shape on the day of
the March I to be Wells Barnet
a groundbreaking investigative
journalist an anti-lynching advocate
refused to move to the back and proudly
marched under the illinois banner the
co-founder of the n-double a-c-p
mary church terrell join the parade with
22 founders of the Delta Sigma Theta
Sorority an organization created by
female students from Howard University
in these ways and more black women
persevered despite deep hostility from
white women in the movement and at great
political and physical risk on the day
of the parade suffrages assembled to
create a powerful exhibition the surging
sections of the procession included
international suffrages artists
performers and business owners floats
came in the form of golden chariots and
enormous Liberty Bell and a map of
enfranchised countries on the steps of
the Treasury Building performers acted
out the historical achievements of women
to a live orchestra the marchers carried
on even as a mob blocked the route
hurling insults and spitting at women
tossing cigars and physically assaulting
participants the police did not
intervene and in the end over 100 women
were hospitalized their mistreatment
widely reported throughout the country
catapulted the parade into the public
eye and garnered suffragists greater
sympathy national newspapers lambasted
the police and congressional hearings
investigated their actions during the
parade after the protest the women's
journal declared Washington has been
disgraced equal suffrage - scored a
great victory in this way the March
initiated a surge of support for women's
voting rights that endured in the coming
years suffragists kept up steady
pressure on their representatives
attended rallies and petitioned the
White House eanes milhollin a woman on
the white horse campaign constantly
throughout the United States
and despite suffering from chronic
health problems she did not live to see
her efforts come to fruition in 1916 she
collapsed while giving a suffrage speech
and died soon after
according to popular reports her last
words were mr. president how long must
women wait for Liberty the full voting
inclusion would take decades in 1920
Congress ratified the 19th amendment
finally granting women the right to vote
when we make videos about the history of
justice we often wonder what's next
luckily for us within our community
there is a chorus of young voices
demanding a brighter future check out
some of these ideas on the ted-ed
student talks youtube channel or visit
ed dot Ted calm slash student talks to
learn more about the program
[Music]